[Music]
it didn't seem at all the sort of film
where the actor completely changes and
oh my god is it really him no no you
meant to know it's me obviously easily
labeled as vanity project for this actor
and all that stuff so how did you end up
getting the part you just have to hate
harry potter
[Laughter]
[Music]
in schindler's list i played armon gert
who was the commandant of a nazi labor
camp i mean and it was exciting because
it felt like everyone
is there because they love murder i
would like so much to
touch you in your loneliness
what that what would that be like i
wonder i remember definitely thinking of
who do i know that are armon gert like
it was in fact harvey weinstein who
saved it
i'd met wes a couple of times on the set
he had been very abrasive and arguably
abusive to people and that's one of the
pleasures actually a lot of west's
obsessions than mine i think of that we
were twinned
[Laughter]
[Music]
i know what you're thinking what on
earth did i just watch well you know the
new harry potter reunion special came
out and we were talking about that we
started talking about how like ray finds
is in there and we thought it'd be
really funny if what if like ray finds
was voldemort in the special and then it
just kind of got us thinking about like
what if ray fines wasn't ray fines and
was actually just voldemort gq has this
whole series of videos where you know a
celebrity breaks down their most iconic
roles and you know they break down their
career and i think their videos are
great what if we take that gq video with
refines recontextualize it the way we
always do like our rated r things the
epitome of evil also is an actor and has
this
dreams and goals yeah
yeah his own evil dreams and goals so
behind all of the humor and actually
trying to create a final product this is
a video that's gonna explore the sort of
effects that hollywood uses to do face
manipulation there's a lot that goes
into that and it's a lot more complex
and complicated than you might realize
and in this video we're gonna explore
all about that as we try to create that
thing you just watched
yeah so the next steps i i like the idea
of basically limiting the scope of work
to just using that gq video this is
essentially just a parody of that type
of format insert celebrity breaks down
his career by also just using the
footage that gq has uploaded it gives us
a consistent thing to work with you know
we have two camera angles one looking
directly at them one looking kind of
from the side like three quarter angles
and then insert a few shots from some of
the movies that he's been in i was
thinking we can maybe limit it to like
three movies obviously harry potter it's
a biopic after all i mean i'm thinking
grand budapest with a mustache on
voldemort is so funny it's like too
funny yes what else should we do so oh
schindler's list schindler's list
because voldemort wasn't evil enough for
him a dark lord we're not yeah dark lord
not yet
ultimate evil right there so step one
then let's get a cut together that is
working and really funny matt while you
edit the video let's go ahead and start
looking into how the original voldemort
effects were done kind of a little bit
of a historical deep dive into that and
maybe we'll get some inspiration on how
they did it maybe we can incorporate
some of that into our own workflow
there's the whole concept of you have a
nose and you cannot remove that with
makeup it's an additive process but
visual effects you can remove stuff it
can be a subtractive process so let's
take a look at some voldemort scenes
here of course one of the best scenes in
the entire movie series is the fight
between dumbledore and volley dude look
at this shot like right here this isn't
just a close-up it's extreme with an x
they named games after this
[Music]
and do we know in this one exactly what
they replaced because obviously you can
see like the poor detail it's hard to
determine what is a different texture
versus what is just simply out of focus
they basically added a bunch of makeup
to ray finds here to make him look more
sickly including a bunch of like
temporary tattoos for the veins and of
course white makeup to make them very
pale but the nose there's obviously no
nose they had to replace it and the
general pipeline here is pretty complex
because first off it involves 3d
tracking the head so that you can
actually know how his head is going to
be moving through 3d space they had a
track and an actual 3d model of this
sort of flattened nose with the slits
and whatnot and the poor texture detail
around all of it and they had to pretty
much do it for his entire face
they did that so that they can pick and
choose when to just replace his nose
versus having to replace his entire
cheek why would you have to replace the
entire cheek as well those pesky nose
shadows nose shadows you hate them you
hate them i mean look at this right here
there's a very strong light coming from
the frame right if he had a full nose
there there'd be a very triangular
shadow lying on the right of his cheek
but notice there's no shadow there and
that's one of those things that makes
this a little bit more challenging than
might be intuitive because there's a lot
more work that has to go into this so
for a shot like this for instance where
it is an extreme close-up i'm willing to
bet both cheeks
all the way down to his lip and his
eyebrows i'm willing to bet everything
right here except for immediately around
his eyes is completely replaced with a
cg model it's tracked to his head but
also to his face
the pores stretch and yeah and the
benefit of those points all over the
face is you have different levels of
depth from the camera so when the face
is moving you're getting an
understanding in 3d space of where all
these points are in relation to each
other so you can solve for that and you
can figure out oh this point must be
further back in space than this point
this is the three dimensionality that we
look for when removing noses so that's
essentially their workflow is it a lot
of work absolutely especially with the
sheer number of shots that they had to
do for every movie okay so as far as the
actual workflow pipeline here we've got
three different types of effects we're
trying to do some of these might be just
2d effects like if he's not really
moving much we can get away with just
photoshopping the nose and then tracking
it that's a great 2d effect you won't
really notice but once he starts moving
around a little too much we might get
some lighting changes some shadows that
might be happening that's when we might
need to start getting into a little bit
more 3d territory jordan i know you
started looking into doing some head
tracking object tracking type pipelines
where where are you at with that i'm
looking into it
uh no i mean we've got the option in c40
we can do it with the object tracking in
there let's make that your goal sweet my
goal for the week is to get a deep fake
going of voldemort here and we'll talk
about that more here in a moment you
know we've obviously done a lot of deep
fakes in the past you know everything
from luke skywalker
tom cruise keanu reeves but i've always
kind of been a supporting role in those
projects so i know a lot about deep fix
but not too much about the actual
explicit process and so i'm hoping to
get niko's help and actually do a whole
deep fake beginning to end
how do you do them they're pretty simple
actually deface lab is the app that i've
been using and really what it comes down
to is you need pictures of faces
specifically of the person's face you're
going to be putting the d-pig on and the
face that you're training for the deep
fake you're going to need about 5 000
pictures of each and they need to be
high-res they need to be clear and
ideally from all different angles all
different expressions and all different
lighting conditions the more variety and
data you can give the computer the more
variety and data you will be able to
represent with your deep fake and other
than that you need a bunch of vram so
you need a nice gpu like a 30 90 and you
need time that's it i've already started
the process of collecting all of the
voldemort faces from the entire movie
pretty much every single time
voldemort's on screen i'm going to be
using that as far as like the actual
images of ray fines i'm going to train
it on the entirety of that interview but
i also am going to try to pull from
various other interviews with ray finds
in there you know this one's a bit of an
interesting sort of twist on deep fakes
because you're used to seeing like
someone's normal looking face being put
on someone else's normal looking face
but voldemort is anything but normal
he's missing a nose how is the deep fake
gonna handle that committing to the deep
fake for all of the interview footage
introduces a slight problem in that
we're probably gonna have to spend
pretty much the entirety of the next two
to three days just developing the model
before we could even really begin doing
the deep fakes so i'm worried we might
not even really begin to start working
on all of the interview footage until
thursday or friday it's very up in the
air right now as to whether or not the
deep fake is gonna work with the
protruding nose i say we should do some
of the shots in like lockdown from the
interview because we can compare them to
the deep fake stuff and see if it's like
if it actually makes sense to do the
deep fake you know if the d-pick
actually looks better or even comparable
there's a level of control that we can
get with lockdown in 2d and after
effects that we can't really get with
the deep fake all right three two one no
no
what's up dean
what's up nick hey you look really chill
dude yeah i was just taking a load off
trying to get some weight off my foot
you know i actually uh
strained my ankle and uh
had to put it in a boot sometimes
feet need splints but sometimes our
brain needs a splint that's why i want
to tell you about today's sponsor better
help so i'm actually a user of
betterhelp and i'm a big fan of the
service it's a online platform to
connect you with a therapist it's not a
crisis line it's not a self-help room
this is licensed therapists giving you
professional advice on how to deal with
whatever you're going through when i
made the decision that i wanted to get
into therapy i was really daunted by
like what do you do do you call an
office do you
check with your insurance i had no idea
but better help makes it super easy you
just sign up for an account put in your
information you can get connected with
the therapist in less than 48 hours
being able to find somebody really
easily was super comforting to me and i
immediately connected with this person
and been on there for about five months
now and i really think it's a great
investment i think you know we pay x
amount for car insurance i think you can
crash your car and get a new car but you
can't crash your brain it's a worthy
investment better health has over 20 000
therapists that you can connect with
with a membership you can schedule
weekly phone or video chats with your
therapist from the comfort of your own
home you don't have to wait in some
weird waiting room better help is super
affordable much more affordable than a
lot of therapy options out there
services available for clients worldwide
it makes therapy really accessible and
low stress you can send a message to
your therapist anytime and expect a
timely response scheduling a meeting is
super easy it's hit a button and that's
your appointment for the next week
there's no calling receptionist there's
no insurance cards there's no barrier
between you and getting the help you
need so there's over a million people on
this platform taking concrete steps
towards building their happiness so if
you want to join them head over to
betterhelp.com
corridor crew and get 10 percent off
your first month that's betterhelp.com
or crew hit that link in the description
made a big difference in my life and i
think there's a lot of people out there
right now who could benefit from it
is that
is that baltimore
okay so so what is lockdown we keep
throwing this word around lockdown what
it is is it's a plug-in for after
effects or fusion that allows us to do
something pretty cool with the 2d track
you designate points around your object
it could be anything but for our
purposes we're using faces and it
creates a mesh from those points and
then within that mesh it tracks your
movement in the scene and then it
creates a precomp of your footage that
is a stabilized version of whatever
you're tracking within the mesh anything
you want to put within this mesh it will
stay locked down to this footage right
so once you go into your main comp you
can see that it's following
his face as he's moving and it's also
distorting and warping around his face
in 2d to match the shadows i have
several shadow and light layers around
our voldemort nose here to match
the color values and black levels of the
opposite side of his face where the
light isn't hitting in our final we have
a much more convincing shadow on his
right side here and it's a lot easier to
do because it's locked down the shadow
as well tracks realistically to his face
it all just sticks i could give him some
face tats sick face tats
oh look at this post maloney
always tired tired always
look so i mean you can do so much with
this it's really just the limitation is
uh your imagination in terms of what you
want to put on this man's face honestly
some of these lockdown shots that you've
done already look incredible and at the
very least deliver the point and that's
all we're trying to do at the end of the
day is just like it's it's this is a
joke this is a stupid little parody joke
video that is hopefully gonna make some
people go
that's about the best we could ever hope
for so while matt is busy uh working
away in lockdown we do have a couple
special shots that need a little bit
more and that's because we have some
three-dimensional movement from wraith
there's really no way around that in 2d
so we have to now enter into the 3d
world and that's where i come in there's
one shot in particular that is the
biggest issue and that is the shot from
schindler's list where he literally
turns around to reveal himself and
that's got a really strong side light
that's casting a lot of sharp shadows
based on his nose and just his facial
geometry what i came down to as far as
execution is a two-pronged assault the
first was to track the head considering
we're using pretty compressed black and
white footage there's not a great way to
do that especially when he turns all the
way around so i decided forget it i'm
just going to do it manually over the
course of 20-25 minutes i just manually
keyframed a geometry of a 3d model of
voldemort that we downloaded once i got
it aligned to the shape of rave space
which is very easy because of course he
is voldemort so you know you download a
voldemort model and it's going to fit
rave space then it's just a grindy
affair of going five frames at a time
lining it up approximately then cutting
those in half going two frames at a time
and just until you feel like it's in a
good spot the end result is kind of
haunting but it gets the job done again
the main reason that we needed to use 3d
was for these no shadows right so once
the head was tracked it just came down
to matching the lighting and texturing
the head we then bounce it out and send
it over to compositing i actually used
two approaches in compositing i used the
3d model that we exported and i also
used lockdown as well and what i did is
i used the 3d model up until the point
where he was facing camera and then i
blended it into a lockdown track so that
i have a really nice 2d solve for when
he's facing the camera and i also get
those really nice crisp harsh shadows
that change as the nose rotates away
from the light it's a pretty simple
approach but the difference in having
those shadows versus not having those
shadows makes a huge difference and even
though it only lasts about 12 to 14
frames it helps solidify the comp much
more so than if we just did it all in 2d
about a mile off i'm very excited it's
going well though
um yeah no the defects are looking very
very promising we're right in the final
stages of like merging all the final
shots together so i'm gonna go see what
that looks like but
i'm pretty optimistic yeah
we're excited can you tell
all right so deep face there are a few
interesting things i learned so once i
kind of went through all that stuff with
nico i had to do all the grunt work of
actually assembling and collecting all
of the face sets of voldemort here and
then also all of the face sets of ray
fines from the interview so that we can
train a computer to create voldemort
from scratch but also to create refines
from scratch and then to take those
creations and make them kiss
[Music]
and that's what we commonly know as deep
fakes so i was going through all these
movies and i got to the fifth one here
and i noticed something interesting i'm
just going to go ahead and show you the
shot as it plays out in the movie
he starts smiling right there at the end
he's like oh it's just harry potter ah
my scar hurts oh and then dumbledore
shows up out of the fire oh no so he
goes from smiling voldemort to er oh god
his true enemy just showed up but here's
the thing did that shot look familiar to
you because it looked familiar to me
hear those shots side by side
and back in that's right it's the exact
same shot it's not like some different
take it's literally the exact same
footage has been taken out reversed and
put in a different spot of the edit just
like five seconds later the vfx are
different between the two shots look at
this here is the shot the first one and
then i go to the next frame
[Music]
look at that they're different
voldemort's nose changes look at him in
this first shot and then the second shot
and then also the background changes
look at this
it's a whole separate background the
ground is different that highlight just
completely disappears these things get
brighter whatever they are not that big
of a deal i just find this very
interesting because that means that
these were two completely separate
visual effects shots that were treated
as such
a deep fake is not enough you still got
to be a good compositor to make it work
and one of the things we discovered is
that voldemort never blinks the deep
fake training doesn't know what
voldemort looks like with his eyes
closed so every time ray finds in the
interview blinks voldemort's eyes just
kind of like twitch and so what we ended
up doing was going through and just for
the times where he blinks we're masking
back in his original eyelids over the
top of the deep fake
and because blinks are so fast it
actually works like it's kind of hard to
tell so you end up with like sort of the
smorgasbord of lockdown shots some
cinema 4d shots and deep fake and some
just regular old-school masking to pull
off this final effect it's not as simple
as just oh i made a deep fake or it's
not as simple as just like oh i just did
some photoshop it's like it's all of it
combined working in parallel to deliver
a final shot and that's why i like this
video a lot i'm very excited about it
but now it is time to show everyone else
because i think it's really funny and i
want to see what their reactions are
going to be
just remember that
voldemort is a real person with real
feelings
[Music]
it didn't seem at all a sort of film
where the actor completely changes and
oh my god is it really him no no you
meant to know obviously easily labeled
as vanity projects
honestly
you just have to hate harry potter
in schindler's list i played armon gert
who was the commandant of a nazi labor
camp i mean and it was exciting because
it felt like everyone
is there because they love murder i
would like so much to
touch you in your learning
it was in fact harvey weinstein who
saved it
and that was a couple of times on the
set he'd been very abrasive and arguably
abusive to people and that's one of the
pleasures actually a lot of western's
obsessions than mine i think that we
were twinned
[Laughter]
and that's it
that was uh the villain quarterly video
on voldemort's iconic career that's
really funny they all feel like they're
the same thing it's really cohesive it's
really nice the deep fake turned out
really good you guys did a great job
compositing it which is such an
important step in the process and truth
be told though i'm really impressed with
how well all just the 2d effects stack
up like you just get a good looking
frame photoshop style and it just works
for the rest of the video all right now
that we have established villains
quarterly i think we should take a look
at some other villains leave a comment
down below with some suggestions and you
know maybe the next issue will feature
that villain what if you turned gollum
back into andy's yes
then josh brolin thanos mcdaniel's a
real guy
so yeah anyway leave a comment down
below with your suggestions we'll read
them and thanks for watching
no wait and subscribe hit that dinga
ding